anybody who's ever dated somebody knows
that like there is the quote-unquote
honeymoon period you present your best
self you're going to basically play
everything up what happens is later in a
relationship people will Retreat back to
their emotional home and all of a sudden
they'll start to behave differently
classic tropiers like you see like a dad
come home from work they sort of slump
through the door all they want to do is
get to the couch get the cold beer turn
on the TV and turn off their brain if
you do what you did at the beginning
there would never be an end and the
version of this that I try to like make
as a practice is to have honey I'm home
energy have you ever seen I Love Lucy
back in the day the guy opens the door
honey I'm home and you can just hear
from The Voice get ready for a great
ball of energy coming your way that is
going to be loving that is going to be
affectionate it's going to be playful
and flirtation is a charming and so one
simple practice to develop the skill of
enthusiasm is to have this honey I'm
home energy which is before you walk
through a door whether it's to a meeting
whether it's to your house whatever it
is just decide to walk in with that
honey I'm home energy you only need to
do it for like 45 seconds you'll like
the way it feels they will respond to
you differently and it'll just carry